SPEAKER 1: With almost
500 sessions at NEXT 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see "Best
Practices from Google SRE:
How You Can Use Them
With GKE + Istio,"
then stay tuned, because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When your critical cloud
applications are up
and running, you
cannot afford downtime.
And so you probably have
many systems in place
to prevent and monitor
your apps, to find out
when they aren't happy.
Thankfully, things can
get a little easier
for you using a service mesh and
standard reliability practices.
OK, so what's a service mesh?
A service mesh is
a way to automate
key functions of your network
for interrelated applications.
And to accomplish
that, it's critical
that this tool be transparent
and language-agnostic,
giving you increased flexibility
instead of more integration
headaches.
Think of a service mesh
as an open platform
to manage how services
interact, and give
you insight into how they
depend on each other.
It does all of this
by adding a sidecar
proxy, either a container or
a little buddy for your VM
that will handle inbound
and outbound traffic,
apply policies, and
collect metrics.
But don't worry, you don't need
to build all this on your own.
Istio is an open
source service mesh
that you can use
for great monitoring
right from the start, providing
key metrics for observing
the health of your services,
like traffic, errors,
and latency.
Each key metric
is useful to help
you track if services
outages are happening,
or where a disruption might be
occurring in your service mesh.
With Istio, you get automated
collection and dashboarding
of traffic errors and
latency right out of the box.
You can export these logs
into BigQuery, Stackdriver,
or any third party tool that you
like, and do precise analysis,
alerting, and reporting.
That way, you and your
SREs can understand
exactly what's happening in your
system when there is an issue.
Using Istio, you
can also roll out
new versions of a
service carefully,
deploying a canary test for
analysis and measurement
before you roll
out to all traffic.
This improves on basic
Kubernetes functionality,
which would split traffic
across all pods evenly.
But with Istio's tools, you
can say, test this new pod
with 1% of traffic,
without having
to deploy exactly 100 pods.
To hear more about
reliability best practices,
Dickerson's Hierarchy
of Reliability Needs,
as well as SLOs, SLAs,
and SLIs, check out
the full talk at the
Cloud YouTube channel,
and don't forget to subscribe
for more great NEXT Rewind
content.
Thanks for watching.